hola soy shalkan bienvenidos a khan
academy estás a punto de embarcarse en
tu propia aventura de aprendizaje
nuestro sistema se adaptará a tus
necesidades para eso lo primero que vas
a hacer es una evaluación preliminar muy
breve que te tomará unos cuantos minutos
y será la adecuada para ti de esta forma
el sistema detecta dónde estás en tu
curva de aprendizaje si al hacerlo te
encuentras con algo que consideras
difícil o que no has visto solo da clic
en donde dice no lo he visto antes y
nosotros adaptaremos los ejercicios para
ti estoy seguro de que si le das la
oportunidad al sitio vas a aprender más
matemáticas de lo que hubiera creído
posible buena suerte